同学们好，咱们上课。
挺长时间没讲公开课了是吧？那今天的内容是最近最流行的啊，大家也最关注的一条赛道。AI剧有叫AI漫剧的是吧？都可以，因为它有不同的风格。
有动画呀，有仿真人啊，就是有各种风格。现在。
呃，这个AI剧大家都在关注，有一这个比较前卫的同学已经在学习了啊，那我们今天就来探讨。
AI剧一个人对吧？一人剧组吗？现在说一人剧组啊，就是你自己把这个剧搞出来这件事情到底行不行得通，以及应该怎么做啊。
先说答案，当然写得同，否则咱们今天这节课讲啥呢？就是教大家啊，然后回答几个在AIG这条赛道，同学们问我最多的几个问题啊，今天统一解答一下这个。
第一个问题，AI剧的。
红利有多久或者是过去了吗？是不是红利结束了呀？有些平台在下下架劣质AI剧了呀，每次有新东西都有同学问这个问题啊呃在这里再解答一遍啊。
首先我不太相信红利这个词儿，因为为什么呢？新东西刚出来的时候啊。
会有一段时间。
管理比较混乱，然后呢，平台在抢资源。
这么说吧。
AM慢刚出来的时候，平台大量的收，甚至有一段时间不分质量的收，只要你能统固出来。
他就以一个很低的价格买走，比如说2万块钱对吧？2万多3万多，当然你要符合他的标准啊，多少分钟以上，然后他就买走你用AI生成。有过那么一段时间，同学们，那种情况你如果称那种为红利的话，那你就要搞清楚它是为什么。因为中国的这个商业竞争啊。
一般是倾向于先砸钱抢份额，然后再慢慢整理质量，整理收费标准，对吧？当年滴滴记得吧，这个最明显不过的对吧？有段时间赔钱抢客户，培养大家用滴滴打车的习惯。然后呢，慢剧也是这样。
他在那段时间呀，他在抢。
抢剧啊填库存。所以你可以理解那段时间确实质量很差对吧？质量很差，有些人会误以为那是红利，同学们也没啥红利。你想想看嗯，价格都很低的对吧？而且那些剧基本上没有剧本都是这个这个用小说直接生成啊。
所以说你如果管那玩意儿叫红利的话，那也吃不吃良可啊。所以说每次出来新赛招的时候，我们其实不提倡大家去研究所谓的红利期。这动画有段时间也有这个红利。也就是说当时国家有段时间鼓励说动做动画，也就是说你生成一个动画，每分钟给你贴补多少钱。
那段时间也很有有很多人做觉得这是个红利，对吧？然后不补贴了，这些这类公司就倒倒闭了，吃红利的那些人就倒闭了。然后说红利结束了，那哪有嘛？那现在动漫人家乱了山小妖怪，对吧？人家熊大熊二底羊羊灰太狼，人家不是都坚持在做，都在赚钱嘛？没有所谓的红利期这个说法。
是吧。
所以说AI漫前一段时间网上盛传的什么千人工厂，万人工厂血汗工厂，然后2万块钱一部一下收2000部，那种事情会越来越少，你可以理解那是平台在补贴，而且那种红利你也赚不到钱，你也吃不着，对吧？它稳定下来之后。
必然是卷内容卷剧本啊，所以说没有什么红利。我经常举例子，有些同学说，哎那电商的红利还有吗？我现在还能开网店吗？你干嘛不开啊，你卖吗？你有好产品，你为什么不开个网店，对不对？什么电商的红利结束了吗？消费不会结束的呀，看内容不会结束的啊，所以说。
关于AIM所谓的红利以及之前的那个那些这个市场上的那些传闻，你要有个正确的认知啊，因为这种事情我们经历很多轮了，对吧？每次都这样，所以见怪不怪啊。
那现在。
卷什么呢？所谓的那种劣质定制这一波过去之后，现在进入正常状态的话，卷什么当然是卷内容，卷剧本嘛，卷故事，对不对？现在就是完全在卷故事。所以说现在慢剧需要写剧本，需要统固出一个剧本吗？不能瞎胡生成，不是填酷剧了呀，对吧？所以说咱们。
现在来学习这个是最佳时机啊，我们讲故事。之前那个血汗工厂卷效率的东西，那没必要学，你们也没必要跟我学。就讲故事。这是现在目前的阶段。还有同学会问说，老师AI剧现在可以生成AI仿真人是吧？我每一次就是大家对AI仿真人是最感兴趣的，觉得你看。
会不会取代明星啊，永远不会塌防呀，是吧？然后而且还可以有无数个分身陪伴粉丝们呀、AI明星大有可为呀什么这个呃，会不会取代真人演员啊？呃也有同学有这个疑问啊，首先呃咱们虽然是教大家做AH按理说应该王婆卖瓜。
说哎呀，这是最好的趋势无敌的趋势干掉真人。但实际上啊客观的说呃，不会的，他依然会跟真人共存，为啥呢？啊呃先讲原理，就是说影视这个东西啊，你如果看过我们早期的课。
你可以你可能记得我给大家讲过，我说故事是啥呢？所有的艺术所有的故事是个啥呢？是人与人之间沟通的一个方式。我们借有影视这个桥梁实际是在表达和沟通，我们看剧追剧实际是上是在找我们自己的存在感。我们需要跟某个明星发生连接。
跟某个演员某个角色发生连接，然后呢找我们自己的存在感啊，这其实是个本质问题。呃，你能明白，或者是你打概能听懂就行呃，他就取代不了，因为真人就是真人。
我们沟通，我们要的是真人，要的是活人，他一定是共存。那AI的东西，那就是共存嘛。
对吧这是个原理。第二个呢再讲一个现象。那动画片和三维其实早就有了，那也没见识说真人明星变少了呀。你说那那早就拍过三维动画的是吧？美国那三维多逼真啊，也也早就出来动画片了，都从他妈迪士尼早期黑白就出来动画片了那。
那咋的呀，你有动画片，有三维。
动画三维那个动画片什么的就就就就不要真人了吗？不也没取代嘛？对吧？那AI也取代不了。
共存你现在动画片和AI和三维片共这一片就不就在共存嘛啊，所以是个共存啊，这是第二个跟大家讲的啊，第三个是。
AI剧的趋势。很多同学说，那AI剧红利啊，你如果是进入正常状态，那未来会怎样？同学们未来是这样，未来就不会有AI剧这个词儿，不是说AI剧消失了，是他已经融入我们所有的创作当中。
以后这个剧当中会有大量的AI辅助。比如说演员是真人，但是后面那个特效是AI的那你说算不算AI剧，对吧？或者是这个场景是真的对吧？我这个这个老师是他妈AI的那你说算不算AI剧，对吧？所以说未来啊这个技术啊，他会应用在我们各个方面。
啊呃。
所以咱们一定要学，因为你拦不住它的，对吧？就像智能手机现在融入我们所有人的生活，那你说我不行，我就用99个按键的那个诺基亚，那你买东西你都买不了嘛，对吧？订机票就定不了嘛，所以说这个技术我们必须学，只是它未来会融入我们的生活。
你越早学越能占到所谓的红利和先祭啊，嗯你就像包括现在这个这个已经有大量的，就是说我们大家不必标榜自己是AI剧，对吧？我只是环境用AI生成的人用真实而眼啊那这种剧现在也是非常多的。
所以说未来啊AI剧大有可为啊，肯定是这个技术一定要用的。然后。
我们。
为什么选择讲这个课呢？当然是因为AI剧现在开始讲故事了啊，我们是编剧课啊，讲故事是我们擅长的东西啊。所以说啊我来给大家讲第二个呢，我本身也是个理工男，同学们啊，这个计算机那一套计算机的运行逻辑，AI的工作原理啊。
难不倒我，当然了，我也是学啊我也是学这个新东西。现在为什么这种课系统的少，对吧？因为老师们，那些职业的老师们他还没来得及学呢，对吧？就得像我们这种。
愿意学的人啊，先去学，然后再分享给大家，相当于是探路者。这就说到咱们这套课啊，同学们有一段时间啊，我就在想我给大家讲讲课67年了，我现在也在各个大学讲课啊，包括北京电影学院，我也在那讲编剧课，我就在想说哎呀，你说我当时是怎么。
对吧在网上就所谓的火了嘛。当然咱这个火是垂直赛道的火啊，同学们，因为我是讲编剧课的，我不希望有无关的流量，对吧？我不可能说哎，我们去蹭点热点，是是是去炮轰一下谁是吧？这个蹭点呃流量，那个没有必要啊，因为那些流量他不他对。
写作不感兴趣，他只是泛流量啊，我们在垂直赛道已经是是是是绝对的霸主啊。编剧课我经常想为什么呃，你说我是特别好的编剧吗？我不清楚，也不一定，因为我毕竟没写那么多东西，对吧？
产量不高，你说我是特别好的老师吗？或者是我在互联网。
这个这个流量低，那我就是最好的老师吗？一定不是比我讲的好的老师也肯定有。那你说我为什么？
有那么多呃学生跟我学对吧？大部分同学其实现在在听课的大部分同学，你们甚至都不是我的粉丝，你们只是可能收藏了我这个课程合集是吧？然后呢，就甚至都没关注我就听呗，对吧？就学呗，为什么呢？我后来通过马斯克啊讲的这个第一性原理嘛。
四个爱说第一性原理，咱也讲过这个事儿，我就总结出来了，我的课程就是我的课程的第一性原理是什么？不是讲的好，也不是说我。
那个那个教大家的知识有多专业，多过硬，本质上是什么呢？本质上我们的课程解决的是那些对故事创作，或者是对影视有兴趣，但没有门路的人的一个入行的问题。也就是说，我们课程最大的价值。
或者是它的底层逻辑，是我让很多有影视梦想，有创作梦想的人，哎，发现这个事儿。
可行，本来他做不了，对吧？我记得印象很深的我一个学生呃，应该是最早的一批学生之一啊。呃有一次来北京，他说想见见我啊，我就我就见他了，结果他突然。
很很很突然的啊就突然给我下跪了。
我说你干啥，我赶紧把它扶起来，我说你干啥，你有话就说，你想说什么？然后他表达了一个很淳朴的一个原因，他说他是一个农村小孩吧？学历也不高。然后呢，本来以为自己跟影视完全没有没有关系，对吧？
但是通过我的课，从写剧本开始，后来当制片儿，后来自己开公司，后来又融资啊，还多轮融资啊，短剧慢剧。然后现在是一个影视的小老板。我说你看这个就是就是意义，对吧？你说他学的有多好也未必见得，是吧？写的有多好，也未必见得。
但是呢给了他一个可能性。所以说这是咱们课程的底层逻辑。也就是因为这个底层逻辑。你看咱们才会去短剧出来了，我们就讲短剧，慢剧出来了，我们就讲慢慢剧AI剧。有些非常老派的人就不理解呀，觉得你好好的一个编剧老师看起来道貌岸然的也算是行业内。
有点名气的人竟然去下探讲短剧，讲慢句，实在是什么对吧？登不了大雅之堂。我本来也有这样的想法，觉得讲这些不高雅。后来想明白这个第性原理之后，我就大大方方讲了那。
短剧和AI剧能帮助更多人入行啊，能帮助更多人实现这个梦想呀，对不对？我如果真的把自己纯定位成一个编剧老师，那我讲完一套编辑课，我应该在讲什么呢？我应该在讲故事对于人生的影响。故事对于这个经济的影响。
故事在商场商战当中的应用，对吧？我如果是就是是那种想法的话，我就会去讲这种课。我我开始没有想明白第一性原理的时候，我那些课我也规划过，甚至我都想出那样的书，出版社也很支持跟我约稿？但后来我想我凭什么我为什么要去讲那些东西？
对吧那些东西能帮助谁呀？只能帮我自己装逼，对吧？帮助不了人。我如果真去讲那些，我就太拿自己当回事了，对吧？我就真觉得我我好像是编剧大师，我好像是他妈的呃即使编剧教授，我就应该讲这那我就错了，我就是能帮普通人入行。
对吧所以你看我们后来就。
开始研究做咱们的剧本经济部门，对吧？把大同学们的剧本再去帮着对接甲方是吧？帮大家卖掉，现在每天都有成交，对吧？每天都有同学的剧本被卖掉或者被拍拍出来，对吧？这才是我们课程的第一性原理啊，我们就是专注这件事情是最好。
好吧，所以说AI剧啊也是这样的一个赛道啊，可以帮助大家这个。
进入这个行业啊，刚才说到泛流量，我突然想起来，我就说你看啊如果想要泛流量，你得去蹭，大家可能不太懂互联网啊，互联网我其实玩的挺溜的。前段时间那个很多人问过我一个大流量的问题，我都不接茬，就是足浴足浴火的时候是吧？
张凌赫那个帅哥，然后演了一个将军，然后呢网上就就分成两个阵营，一个一个阵营就说张凌赫好帅是吧？然后另外一个阵阵营呢，就说张凌鹤是粉底液将军，说人家是吧，根本不真实真正的大将军应该是比如说何润东是吧，然后就搬出来翻出来何润东当年的。
那个身材演的那个项羽这那的网上还很多出了很多很多的梗。然后很多人就问我说问我怎么看这个问题。因为确实咱们圈子里面有很多人在这种时候就会跳出来炮轰一下呀，对比一下呀，就可以有很多流量嘛，对吧？我当时一直没吭声。
啊，没课选，我不愿意回回答这个问题，为啥你知道吗？同学们。
因为。
何润东演那个项羽，包括那个戏播的时候，我全程都看了，拍的时候我也知道，因为我有朋友在那个组一播的时候我也全部每一集我都看了，因为我很爱看，我可以明确的告诉大家，同学们。
我为什么不接这个茬？我可以明确的告诉大家，你们甚至都可以自己去回看一下那个戏叫楚楚汉传奇，还是楚楚汉还是争霸，忘了楚汉传奇吧。你们去看一下那个戏，你会发现一个细节，何润东这个角色就他演的这个角色跟其他的主角几乎没有同频出现过。
即便是坐一桌吃饭，我们说红梅宴就是。
项羽刘邦坐一桌吃饭呀。
是吧我如果没记错的话，也基本上都是正盘打啥意思啊？同学们格润东当时演这个角色也遭到了排挤和抵制，嫌他太奶油。什么意思呢？大家觉得这么重的历史题材要找不就不能找奶油小生。
格润东当时就是一个奶油小生，你怎么能演项羽呢？当时也抵制人家的呀，现在又被你们搬出来说，你看这才是男人，当时不是这么说的呀，是不是？所以说没有什么，真的我就不想我不是站我完全不站队，我觉得都挺帅，只不过是这样的事情一再上演。
看我都看腻了，我不能昧着良心站出来炮轰轰张灵鹤啊呀，然后混点流量是吧？然后紧锁眉头，义正言辞的说，我们要维护我们历史剧的什么什么是吧？你干哈呀？你我就是一个帮助同学们进到这个行业的一个老师，好吧。
我们就专注我们的事儿。那再说一个最近的一个更新啊，我由于带很多学生啊经常给大家看剧本。呃，有一个事情我想再强调一下，或者是打个补丁吧。大家记不记得我在最早的时候其实说过一句话，叫用事儿说话。
在事儿上见对吧？然后呢，我最近看同学们写的剧本搞的故事有大量的信息堆砌，也就是说不是故事啊，比如说用对白。
喊出了所有的信息，我以前怎么对你的，我以前是干什么的？我现在什么情况，我现在欠着钱，你什么情况，你们家又怎么着，你一顿就是没有用事儿说话。因为我早期的时候我就讲过这个理念啊，剧本是用事儿说话的，但是大量同学出现这个问题，那我作为一个老师，我就得先反思我自己。
我后来想了想啊，可能是因为我在讲课的时候，我虽然说过用事儿说话，但是我在大量的课程或者是大量的篇幅里面一直在讲信息节拍也是什么意思呢？我经常给大家讲，你看在这里我们有什么任务？比如说在这里我们需要交代。
角的现状。比如说在这一轱辘，我们需要让交代，让主角happy起来，甚至谈个恋爱，对吧？就说这一骨节儿的这一骨节儿的信息节拍的它的目的和作用。我经常强调这件事情，导致很多同学可能就误以为这是第一要。比如说这一段我们要交代。
主角这个处境不好，很穷是吧？他就用对话把这些信息交代了，他觉得就完成任务了。我后来就反思啊，因为如果是一个同学出这样的问题，那可能是他的问题。但如果有很多同学出这样的问题，那就一定是我的问题是吧？我就后来就反思这件事情，在今天啊给大家打个补丁剧本。
第一要物是事儿不是信息，当然要推进信息，否则你剧情不往前走嘛，但是还是要用事儿来推。比如说举个例子，刚刚今天早上是吧？有个同学发给我了一个剧本，上来呢他写的是一个短句啊，短剧经常有低开，比如说屌丝开场，然后呢写这个男生。
呃，在家里。
然后呢，欠房租手机不断的响，然后呢弹出。
那个文字他还写知道吧？知到时候文字就弹在屏幕上，然后房东催催房租。然后呢啊里面有说你已经欠多少个月了，欠我多少钱啦，再不给你就给我滚，对吧？我要报警，什么什么就写了这样一场戏，发给我，我早上就看了。
就跟他沟通，我说你你这么长的一坨，就就全是手机信息，没有画面呀，没有对抗呀。他说你看我骂的这么凶，这还不是对抗吗？对吧？我说不是呀，我说你看啊，你房东发信息要房租，你不就想讲男主，他就。
表达信息是表达出来了对吧？主角很穷嘛，交不起房租嘛，现在处境不好吗？我说那你那你让房东直接来呀，对吧？你让他来呀，为什么要发信息呢？来就比发信息要强烈呀，对吧？但是来如果指着鼻子骂，那依然不是事儿。
对吧我说来堵你，但你假装不在家，房东掏钥匙要进去，你要怎么躲，你看这不就来事儿了吗？还是要用事儿去去去解决问题。咱们很多同学啊经常写这种其实我在课上其实是讲过了呀，要画面动起来。
是吧用事说话。
包括昨天吧有个同学写的他那个角色，女扮男装还是男扮女装，我忘了。
反正呢也是在那全部是内心内心的OS。比如说女扮男装，哎呀，内心哎呀，我这个男生我们应该怎么着啊，就吧我能不能混过去啊，这个我待会对吧？全是这种，我说你写这么多OS干什么？就我要表达一个女扮男装这个人他他现在。
很容易穿帮，或者是他不自信，对吧？或者这么一个窘迫。
我说你能上手就不要说话。我说女扮男装上手的戏你不会写吗？碰到哪儿是吧？这多简单的一个一个表达方式，而且有视觉，有表演，然后也能让观众感觉到，比比如说不小心被别人碰到了，别人怀疑嗯。
他怎么没有是吧，你不就来了吗？
你这是叭巴什么呢？能上手的事儿，为什么要说呢？这就是很多同学出现这个问题啊，今天在这里再强调一下，你包括还有的同学也是反正都是这几天的作业，有的同学写这个这个呃女主是道吧？在学校被霸凌，这个很多同学特别喜欢写这种西。
然后呢，被霸凌就一帮人在那骂他，我说你看全是台词，骂他穷，骂他什么你妈在路边摆摊什么什么在那骂。
我说你这种戏霸凌戏怎么又写成纯台词了，说老师不是纯台词啊，我扇了他一巴掌啊，对吧？我说那他妈就那一巴掌也算不上一个冲突和对抗，对不对？我说你看欺负人，你还不会写啊，就会骂呀。
对不对？你你写成一个整蛊或者栽赃加让主角在他最喜欢的人面前出丑。我说这么一场戏不就完成了吗？又有的看，又交代了主角，经常被欺负，对吧？我说这这干坏事还不会吗？整个栽赃戏嘛？
对不对？
所以说啊在这里跟大家强调一下，就是用事儿说话。我记得我早期经常强调这个词儿是吧？后来可能讲着讲着讲了大量的剧本结构、故事、股价，每一个阶段的信息，每一个阶段的任务，导致很多同学把这个事儿给忽略了。我决定最近我整理。
重新整理一下课件是吧？把这个信息节拍改成事件节拍对吧？用事儿来取代之前的信息的一个标识。因为我们经常打股架是什么意思呢？因为很多初学者呀他在写故事的时候，他整体把握不住，他节奏把握不好，所以我们会经常给大家打点，比如说打20个。
点是吧，打20个点，然后每个阶段讲什么任务是什么？结果导致同学误以为完成那些任务就可以了，是吧？还是要用事儿说话，这是给大家打个补丁啊。因为咱们毕竟要讲故事，不管是AI剧还是什么，你可以理解它都是。
用不同的方式在讲故事是吧？那AIG最大的意义是什么呢？AAG最大的意义是再次平权。同学们你定要记住，这个才是平权，每次平权是我们普通人的机会。我为什么总是刚才就是强调里一面我们的课程的意义，帮普通人你如果有钱又有闲去读一个。
这个这个电影学院的硕士，那那你不用跟我学，明白这个意思吧？那儿也有人脉。
对吧那也也能接触到牛逼的人，你去读就行了。但是大部分同学不是没那个条件嘛？没那个时间，没那个精力，没那个钱，对吧？没那个条件，创作平权这件事情是我本人吃了半辈子的红利，对吧？因为我就是一个非常非常普通的外五线小县城。
的小镇做题鸭对吧？那我能入行，或者是我能生存，靠的就是创作平权呀。我们拍的最早的网剧是吧？所做最早的自媒体，那不就是平权嘛？因为如果不平权，你想想看文字不平权，你能写你能发朋友圈吗？你能写东西吗？
你能写公众号吗？图像不平全，大家能每个人现在都天天拍照吗？对吧？影像平权，你可以理解AI剧就是影像平权了，聚集平权，你可以理解影视平权每个人都可以做了。哎，那就很多人也有机会了，对吧？当然了，你说哎每次评权的过程中当然很混乱了，当然会有。
不规范的东西，低审美的东西，低情绪的东西，对吧？当然会有啊，但是它是好事嘛，平权啊，对吧？你是个普通人，如果还在那儿坚守这个比如说啊在我的学生里面经常有同学说，老师我认可你的平权理论，我也知道这是社会趋势。
但是我就是有一个电影梦，对吧？这样的同学特别多，我我从来不打击。我说那这样你先把你先入行，先学会我教你的，先进入这个行业，将来有实力了再去圆你的梦，对吧？嗯，人没没关系啊，因为确实。
一至少有一代人被洗脑，认为电影是什么殿堂是吧？是艺术是最高级的东西，对吧？但实际上对于普通人来说，平权的是最重要了。同学们，现在玩电影的人都都是些不缺钱的人，没有人说我要鼓到一个电影，通过一个电影翻身赚钱，没有。
好吧，那个行业现在都是些已经财富自由的人在玩的，让人人家不靠这个挣钱啊，人家有别的地方挣钱。所以说如果你是一个普通人，一定要关注每一次平选带来的机会，好吧？拥抱它，学习它啊。然后AI剧啊，如果要做AI剧，当然要大量的实操啊。我们今天给大家讲的是理念啊。
今下来给大家讲理念，AI剧需做AI剧需要三个能力，或者是说做AI剧，你要学三件事情，一个是编剧思维。也就是说故事思维。也就是说因为AI剧为什么叫艺人剧组啊，就是你一个人得干不少活，一个人得干扮演不少角色？首先你得是编剧，也就是说你得有编剧思维。
你得鼓捣出剧本来啊啊，这个是咱们的强项啊，舒适区。第二呢是导演思维。一想表达成什么画面，对吧？你的画面是什么？你得心里有数，对吧？你得有导演思维啊，因为它毕竟是影像，是一个画面。
最终形成第三个能力是什么呢？就是工具使用。你可以理解工具使用实际就是制片干的活，做1个AI剧，做1个AI剧要调动的工具，相当于就是你指挥的那些人帮你干活嘛。你得有操纵工具的能力。当然了。
这个这一项啊，我觉得在未来几年里面就越来越容易操作，但是还是有。就说你看现在手机拍照也很容易操作，那些会拍的和不会拍的拍出来还是不一样，是吧？就是好操作跟不好操作。所以说这两个能力更重要一些，编剧思维和导演思维更重要一些。
编剧思维我们今天不多说啊，我因为咱们整套的公开课都是关于怎么写剧本的啊。我们今天主要讲导演思维或者是这个制片流程啊，做出1个AI剧分哪几步啊？有同学说做AI剧做AI影视，是不是就是把一趟指令一一坨文字。
一下扔给某个工具是吧？然后这个工具就给你产生呃这个这个这个视频内容，然后基本上就是这个工作呢完全错误啊，不是这样的，叫一人剧组，就意味着你要做出一个有品质的剧，你还是要用制片思维或者是拍片的思维。
去做这件事情啊做这件事情。第一步，首先确定美学风格。因为AI剧有仿真人嘛？有二维，有三维吧，是吧？有不同的风格，不同的画风啊，确定你的风格是第一位。
啊，你实操一下就知道了，不确定风格，那你下一个镜头怎么办？每个镜头你最后都剪到一块的呀。所以说第一点啊，确定你的美学风格，先有剧本啊，剧本是第一步啊，我是说进入导演阶段之后，第一步是确定你的美学风格啊，确定怎。
第二步设计场景，很多同学总是觉得这个这个生成一段视频是吧？光他说哎，这个人怎么办怎么走。同学们拍戏呀，建组之后啊也是先去看景，你一人剧组做AI剧，也是要先做场景。我一说你就知道为什么了。
同学们，比如说这间房间对吧？你说哎生成一个光头老师在这讲课，对吧？下面有一群学生生成这么一个一个场面。你整部戏100多分钟，200分钟，你这间教室还出不出来。如果还出现的话，你怎么保证他跟上次出现的时候一样，不一样，不就不接戏了吗？
对吧所以说要把场景图全部生出来，甚至各个角度生出来啊，把场景确认掉，那肯定是选角了，或者叫人物设计，对吧？我们拍戏的话叫castty是吧？选角完了就要设计人物了啊，把每个人物角色啊。
生成出来。当然里面有很多戏的技巧啊，根据你的风格啊，把这个人物生成出来。比如说人物的特殊装造也要生出来。我们拍戏也是啊，如果比如说这个角色在戏里面有受伤的妆提前都定掉啊，做过AI剧的同学或者是简单操作的同学都知道啊。
AIG有个巨大的痛点，就是它那个。
人物不连续啊，这个形象啊容易容易容易化了啊，容易跑偏了啊。所以说提前把人物形象啊，每个角度，每种庄造的人物形象全部锁定啊，这都是生图啊，都锁定。把人物生成出来，设计出来啊。呃，刚才讲到说它不连续的问题啊。
其实我们要懂原理，就是说AIAI生成的视频，它为什么有时候不稳定啊，动作不稳定或者人物形象不稳定是吧？运动轨迹不稳定，是因为AI在生成视频内容怎么讲？最通俗啊，它不是通过你的指令在构建图像。
它是在排除同学们就AI永远是在做减法，你可以你只可以这么想，呃，或者是理解成降噪啊，它是降噪的一个过程。那做减法它它就崩不了太长时间，是吧？你可以这么去简单去理解这个问题吧啊，因为多少要知道点原理，所以说按照我们的规定先确定风格。
然后再设计主要的场景图，然后呢再设计主要的人物的形象啊，包括他的每个角度，每个装造啊，然后有了场景和角色了，那么你其实就可以做分镜头了，生成分镜头，AI也有这个功能啊，不用你自己画啊。你只要下指令就行了。
守针尾针你得定好呀，我们叫起伏落符嘛，是吧？起伏落符定好啊，中间人家可以升升这个分镜头的啊分镜头。然后呢，包括你摄影机的摄影机的行动轨迹啊，低器的行动轨迹啊，推拉摇一根是吧？然后镜头这远景中景近景特写是吧？各种镜头啊，镜头的指令。
然后有了这些之后就可以输出画面了啊输出画面了。然后。
都要用哪些工具呢？我们生图啊，生图就用专门生图的工具。你看有些同学喜欢用m journey是吧？banana是吧？lava是吧？用工具去生图啊，然后把所有的图有场景参照图，人物参考图，分镜图参考图。
摄摄影机位置可能是你的文字指令是吧？摄影机的行动轨迹，你也有图，也有参考指令了之后这些东西。
综合起来去升你的影像画面。那在这个过程中，我们就要从需要从生图，把图存下来之后，需要迁移到。
比如说类似于type now这种画布式的啊无线画布式的这种节点式工作流的这种工具上。因为在这种工具上啊呃后期的同学可以把大家操作演示给大家剪一些呃图片给大家看一下啊，你可以告诉他在这个场景下这个人物。
啊，这样的镜头这样去。
还有一些文字补充啊，让他帮你生成画面，甚至可以有参考。同学们啊吧？有参考。我们讲的是这个。
最严谨的流程，比如说给他一段参考图啊，呃给他一段参考视频或者是什么呢？或者你找不到特别好的参考视频，你自己演一遍嘛，或者你自己拍一遍。哎，我要这个运镜啊呃动作啊，我要这样的表演，也就是说在画布上啊呃在t now上大家就。
就就很方便的去生成画面了啊。当然了，生成画面之后，你里面有很多微调的东西啊，比如说呃演技的东西是吧？演技你可以去去打磨，比如说还有留白，也就空镜头是吧？你也可以去精细打磨啊，精细打磨。
然后这些全都弄好了之后呢，还要有配音配乐。
配音配乐。
啊，对吧也可以用工具去生成啊，用工具去生成这个呃。
你要的背景音乐是吧？包括配音嗯，配音啊，现在的AI配音呃技术也是非常好啊，语气呀呃演技啊都是很不错的。但是依然可以用迁移的方法，也就是说这段台词你自己说一遍，你想要什么效果，你自己说一遍，然后再用它的声音再迁移到AI的声音上。
对吧你自己普通话不标准都没关系，对吧？人家可以给你迁移一个标准啊，最后呢所有的素材都有了之后，再进到下一个工具剪辑工具剪辑软件啊，完全可以去剪映嘛，然后去去去去把你的作品再剪出来啊，也就是说用到生图的工具。
然后呢生声音的工具，然后呢把这些东西怎么揉在一块呢？呃，怎么生成画面呢？画布师的工具呃节点是什么工作流啊，工作流的工具。然后呢，这些画面有了各个镜头的画面之后呢，你还要再去剪辑软件上剪出来啊呃当然了，现在市场上有没有鼓吹那种说一站式。
对吧呃在我这儿都能办啊，也有啊也有。但是呢这种一站式的工具啊呃有两个问题吧。第一个问题基本都不是大厂出的啊，所以说他的能力的天花板有限，而且你要理解越傻瓜的操作做出来东西就越难赚到钱。因为人人都可以做嘛。
对吧它品质就呃不好保证，这是第一个问题。第二个问题就是这种一站式的工具，你你的成本也会高，对吧？因为他也要赚一多少钱啊，他也要赚一到这个这个这个偷坑的钱。
嗯，所以说这是一个整个的一个过程啊整个的一个过程。嗯，我自己也在做啊，还是很有意思的啊。同学们可以去去研究一下啊。咱们现在针对AI剧的全流程啊，从写作，从编剧思维到导演思维到工具使用啊。
嗯，咱们有一套呃完整的教程啊，完整的教程。因因为有很多同学啊要借这次评选的机会进入这个赛道。我们以前讲创作者啊，我们需要有什么呃观察力是吧？表达力是吧？想象力各种力啊，以前我们对创作者有各种要求。
现在其实呃呃如果你要做一个剧，其实主要是你的故事审美和画面审美都是审美了啊，这个要求反而高了。也就说你必须清楚你要什么，你的认知是你AI工具的创造天花板。
AI工具创造本质上没有天花板，但为什么大部分人用它来写文章，用它来做内容做不好呢？是因为你的认知天花板有限。你看现在我们其实对动手能力要求越来越低了。也就是说你本来挺犯懒的一个人。
过去肯定不行啊，懒懒人到哪都不行。过去现在你如果是一个很有审美的懒人，我操，恭喜你。
对吧是可以的，但是你得你的认知得你的导演思维和编辑思维，你的认知得达到你才能你要。比如说我们说风格，你连都有些啥风格，你都不知道是吧？王家伟风格，邵氏风格还是什么什么什么那宫崎骏风格，你们你脑子里面没有这个要求肯定不行呀。
所以说。
咱们呃给大家推出一套AIM的全流程的一个陪跑课啊，编剧思维我来教导演思维啊，我们公司一个导演搭档啊，在做呃这方面的一个老师啊，也是我20轮2020年的搭档了，他来教啊，两个老师陪着大家啊。
学习这个AI剧。
然后最近是刚刚开始招生啊，有兴趣的同学呃可以了解一下。然后这个还是说回这个AIG的平权啊。
我们之前。
在教大家写剧本的时候，同学们，我刚才讲过我们讲课的第一性原理是帮助同学们。
帮助一些有有创作梦想，但是没有条件的同学给大家提供一个实现的途径吧。但是同学们。
我之前教大家写剧本最大的痛点就是我这个。
这个途径其实是不闭环。
为什么呢？因为剧本它不是直接to C的剧本它是to B的啥意思啊？就是他不面对观众呀，你剧本没有办法直接给观众看呀，你必须有有甲方给你收走剧本拍出来，他付给你稿费，然后他拍出来才能接触观众，也就是说你必须有个甲方，对吧？这是咱们最大的痛点。
我虽然能够组织剧本经济部门帮大家接活。
但是。
我可以明确的告诉大家，解决的永远是小部分的人的问问题，大部分人的剧本。
对接不到甲方，或者甲方看不上跟甲方的审美不匹配，或者是这个这个这个。
种种原因吧，这一直是咱们的一个痛点，因为这个解决不了，对吧？我给大家讲课就是教大家写剧本。但是现在有AI剧了，你可以非常轻松的在。
几乎所有平台吧，几乎所有视频平台，甚至是一些非视频平台，拼多多什么的现在都有都有AIG的频道，是吧？注册个账号，上传你的剧，参与他的点击分账逻辑写的好不好？看你本事，大家卷故事，而不是卷红利，是吧？老有同学说，那上传上去就能挣大钱，是瞎瞎瞎搞一个。
不好看的也能挣大钱，我要做那种红利，那种红利我交不了，对吧？那种红利我们不会去赌，不会去压啊，也不也没办法交。吃到那种红利的人大概率也不知道自己咋吃的，而且不也很快淘汰了嘛？对吧？我们还是要卷把这个全流程做出来，我们去卷故事，卷内容。
好吧，所以说想要深入学习AIG的同学啊，可以呃联系咱们的助教老师啊，呃深入了解一下咱们现在刚刚开始招生啊，因为这种陪跑课呀，我们每次都只能限额啊就是。
你想想看咱们编剧课得教吧，还是有很多同学在写长句或者是专注写剧本，对吧？这些同学的剧本我得看。然后这个班级AI剧的班级同学们做出来的内容啊，我跟导演老师，我们是双师，这次是两个老师，当然加上班主任和助教他们，对吧？我们主要是两个老师带着大家。
啊，非常牵扯经历。所以说呃也是数量有限，报完就招招晚招满就就截止了。好吧，同学们有兴趣的可以了解一下。
呃，咱们这节课就是给大家介绍一下啊，这个流程你自己在家自学的啊，也可以参考一下这个流程，参考一下我介绍的这些工具，好吧。
呃，下课吧。